Oh sup man I see you got the Andrew
shirt got the white girl doing big
things like he didn't know I was gonna
comment on it it was like [ __ ] you
noticed oh man I knew I should have sat
in the front how did he know how long
you guys been together three years oh
[ __ ] this is real this is real okay so
your parents are fans obviously oh this
is both India white no front okay y'all
surrounding me they can [ __ ] my crab
wars open three years how'd you guys
meet you work you better have a good ass
job white lady
our turf now
we're going to be the [ __ ] secretary
at the engineering firm where he works
you're gonna come correct you yeah you
want you a well welcome you into the
family but there's an income requirement
tell you that [ __ ] right now big notes
she works at she here he said he tried
to flex um he was like she works at the
hospital you know what he didn't say
she's a doctor she works at the hospital
what is she doing it I swear to God if
you say administrative I'm moving to the
[ __ ] back of the room nurse okay
alright you are you a doctor we'll meet
two situations after respect that's
[ __ ] old-fashioned love
exploit the power dynamic charge these
[ __ ] women complaining about that I'm
gonna have a generation of poor dudes
because I like mine can't even [ __ ]
girls if I get famous so what's the
point
I'll just make $40,000 a year power
dynamic daughters you got to do because
she's not she's not unattractive girl
right you whatever and then you guys met
you were like nerves I need these charts
filled out don't you come by my office
we could do it together not him is it
bigger or was it you initiating like
doctor I have a sore throat he was like
let me see open up say